we are decelerating wrist mode under our
trauma boots are at its 29th under here
at 150 meters per second dynamics phase
come back again with wrist mo dynamics
wrist Modi is nominal where are the
daughters and eating leaves active vowed
range netfilter converge with a velocity
correction of points it is essentially
the plan of the ground with the radar
now to the v-club feet Chilton has
separated work on the ground expand
tones deuteros occultation as expected
were you invited I'm the Emily engines
in preparation for power play we're down
to 90 meters per second at an altitude
of 6.5 kilometers and descending this
slightly deal we've got some tweedle
earnings this is in battle you associate
powder film director of communications
at this time we may have lost it already
we're down to 86 meters per second that
adopts you to four kilometers and
descending
we have lost we've lost tones from Earth
at this time this is expected we are
continuing on Odyssey geometry ground
solution equals minus ten point eight
meters vertical velocity of minus 81
primary eight years ago i started a cold
standing by for vaginal separation
tingled odyssey is still strong we are
in powered flight right altitude of 1
kilometer descending about 70 meters per
second single da slowly area 50 meters
per second 500 meters in altitude
standing by for spectra constant
velocity accordion nominal altitude air
five point nine meters we found a nice
flat place we're comin in ready for
Scott grant down to 10 meters per second
40 meters altitude sky crane is started
descending at about point 75 meters per
second as expected expecting Bridal cut
shortly tinkle does he remains strong
can't go down phenomenal yep yo calm
configure if you stable jump on a tree
Jeff you stable
huge f is good touchdown confirmed
receipt